[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here sprinting into the second half of
the season - all the killers in the
hundred dollar villas all the better
swing got no feelings this is the BR
betting shop presented by the Caesars
Palace sports book alongside our betting
insider Kelly Clarkson Stewart arm cabby
Richards they say there are only two
certainties in life death and taxes but
Kelly's best bets have been automatic
this season that's right Kevin the cash
last week with the Ravens plus three you
know I love it when those primetime home
dogs went out right we've now hit seven
best bets in a row proving our season
record two eight and one killing them
who do I like this week I'm gonna stick
around to find out
[Music]
big news this morning Matthew Stafford
is out with fractured bones in his back
Jeff Driskel will start in this place
Kelly Hollow staffers entered injury
affected the line the other current line
here at Caesar's Palace is six and a
half cabby that's way up from the
opening number of Chicago - - and ABS
this is kind of showing you the
importance of betting early and if you
have a Chicago - two and a half ticket
in your pocket I definitely think it's
worth the middle that means if the game
lands three four five or six you're
gonna win both bets all right time to
get started with the marquee matchups of
the week
Packers plus 5 at Panthers plus 5 at the
Packers total 48 the man behind me here
Christian McCaffrey is gonna have a big
game why because Green Bay ranks towards
the bottom in Rush arts allowed at home
this season this one's come down from
five and a half to five means somebody
agrees with me we like the Panthers +5
Sunday night now three and a half the
Vikings are getting at Jerry's world
versus the Cowboys total 48 and a half a
lot gets made of this man behind me Kirk
Cousins in prime time the Kirk Cousins
has done well lately 13 TDs just one
interception his last five games we're
gonna throw all that nonsense out the
window though because we're going back
with my favorite coach coach them are 17
and 5 against a spread after a loss I
like the Vikings getting three in the
hook here Monday night
the Seahawks plus six and a half at the
49ers total of 47 this is gonna be a
really awesome divisional game in the
NFC West on one hand you have Russell
Wilson everybody's back ready to give
him the MVP on the other side you have
the defense and the 49ers that is
allowed an average of nine point six
points in their last five games I leaned
towards a prime-time under here but I
really like the 49ers - six and a half
let's quickly recap those marquee
matchups of the week but in the Panthers
the Vikings and the 49ers I noticed you
didn't have Cincinnati in there and just
like the Bengals the peoples parlay is
own eight and coming off a bye week and
while since he made a change it by
benching their quarterback Andy Dalton I
decided a change of scenery was in order
for the peoples parlay
you come to Las Vegas to have a great
time maybe get lucky and maybe watch a
football game so ladies I need you guys
to help me pick some games I'm Owen
eight in my football picks I'm trying to
change my luck with a coin flip
whichever team you you flip and you
reveal on the back of your hand that's
the team I'm gonna bet on okay who's
last time either of you guys ever flip
the coin to determine any when I got
married we got the Chiefs versus the
Titans Titans I think if I think it's
Titans we've got the Falcons versus the
Saints Saints think Saints all right
[Music]
okay will this end up on the tables as
collateral for Cardinals Cardinals Plus
okay
Buccaneers Cardinals Cardinals good luck
in Las Vegas and hopefully you don't
leave here broke like the rest of us I
need some of that big Nick energy for
our hard reset for the people's parlay
this week the people have chosen the
Titans plus six-and-a-half the Saints
minus thirteen and a half and the
Cardinals plus five Kelly I I like the
underdogs in this one I'm really happy
that those ladies hated the Titans pick
which is really great a solidify their
dogs here but the Saint that's a lot of
points and we'll get to the Cardinals
here in a minute I know it's really been
a rough eight weeks for you cabbie and
as your friend and co-host I want you to
win me too but I really like fading the
people's barley it's just been the best
bet on the show but more importantly I
really am just tired of seeing you mope
around this office we posted this guy on
social media who lost the last leg of a
10 team parlay and that's just kind of
how I feel about you sometimes you miss
Bowl
[Music]
that's my cousin Frankie
oh poor Frankie man I'd like to
sympathize with him but who bets ten
teamers listen who bets parlays to begin
with all of the notes that I was given
this week is we need you to give cabbie
some parlay advice
there is no parlay advice don't bet part
roles I can wait but you bet college
football parlays cabbie that's a little
bit different this is and against the
spread parlay as you can tell it pays
six to one my far less pay like 36 to
one there's a little less risk and a lot
more reward
okay all right guys we're gonna try to
find some winners for week ten let's
take a peek over here at my card cabbie
mentioned that I didn't have the bangles
but he already know I do this week's
theme is ugly uglier and uglier so let's
start off with the ugly one I know it's
no one wants to take the bangles here
catch infinite home total forty four and
a half but you have to think the Ravens
are really feeling themselves after
Sunday night and beaten the Pats Plus
Ryan Finley new quarterback under center
might have some tricks up his sleeve
Baltimore they don't care about
divisional games 1 7 & 1 and their last
night in divisional games including week
6 when these bad boys snuck through that
back door 91% of the tickets on the
Ravens here at Caesar's Palace yet this
one still sitting steady at 10
I like the Bengals next up we have the
Giants minus 3 at the Jets total at 44
so I have a question for all of you at
home the look at headline here was the
Jets - 1 and a half the Jets go on the
road they losing the Dolphins by the way
I told you guys the Dolphins were not
going to win 16 the Giants get throttled
on Monday night by the Cowboys and now
we have a four and a half point line
move can someone make sense of this I
know the sharp guys and the square guys
are all on the Giants today
home alone on an island with the Jets
plus three Rams - four and a half of the
Steelers total 43 and a half here here's
this Rams team nice little short road
favorite healthy there off a bye week
they've covered six straight on the road
they're a sexy pic this week but you
know what Mason Rudolph has
now gotten his team to four and four and
second place in the AFC North this
Steelers team is rejuvenated it has a
lot to play for
I like the Steelers and cabi that is my
car for week ten always stellar home
team's went 12 and one against the
spread in week nine but what they
continue to cache in week 10 in the
latest edition of export analysis Warren
Sharpe says don't bet on it
hi my name is Warren sharp a sharp
football analysis comm I wanted to share
a few edges for sports betting in 2019
on the NFL that you need to be aware of
first and foremost home-field advantage
is not what it once was sports book
operators are giving these teams a
three-point edge but in 2019 home teams
are actually only winning 50% of their
games and they're covering only 43
percent why is that Travel has gotten a
lot easier teams are flying first-class
injuries are easier to deal with you can
bring your medical equipment on the road
you can watch more film on the road the
crowds are a little bit less in two
games the ticket prices are higher more
people are staying at home to watch
these games instead of paying outrageous
ticket prices so you need to take that
in consideration a second element that I
think is important for everybody that
likes to bet on underdogs is you cannot
just pick a dog that you think could
cover this big number and keep the game
close potentially because if you're
underdog is trailing at halftime you are
only covering 29 percent of the time
over the last five years but if you're
leading at halftime you're actually
covering the spread 83% of time and
winning 66% of those games outright you
need to find a dog that you think can
battle throughout but most importantly
potentially enter halftime with a lead
he's an A student at the Baker Mayfield
Academy for mustaches and also an A
student on Twitter he's a great follow
great information you can find him at
sharp football Kelly we all know that
you love to bet underdogs would you make
of Warren's advice Warren's a very sharp
guy hence his Twitter handle and I agree
with him that is exactly what I'm
looking for each and every week those
dogs that are gonna be in that fight
with the chance to went out right cuz
y-you know I get a little greedy I like
that less money speaking of dogs when
our social media audience isn't barking
at you are hating on you for picking
only the underdogs sometimes they tend
to ask good questions so here now
are the minds of the public in pics says
what's the first thing that you'd like
to look at when betting in NFL games all
right it's Monday morning the NFL
Alliance or out the very first thing I'm
looking at is my numbers versus the
books you can get rid of five six seven
games right out of the top remember guys
we're betting numbers not teams so any
differentiation in the line or how I
think a line may move is the very first
thing that I'm looking for on Monday
afternoon Rolla Luka asks please explain
how to read reverse line loops so a
reverse line moves for those of you that
don't know is when a majority of bets
are placed on one side get the line
keeps moving in the opposite direction I
do not have an example for that today in
the NFL so will you college football
yesterday Minnesota Gophers plus seven
versus ten state drops the six and a
half when almost 80% of the tickets were
on the other side that my friends is
reverse line room and that's how you
know you're probably holding a winning
ticket in your pocket Rand incopy wants
to know what is the tipping point from a
ticket count standpoint that defines a
game a square dog so a square dog is an
underdog that the public is backing I
would say we got to start around five to
one tickets
Gabby you actually have a square dog on
your to get today and that is the
Arizona Cardinals even though we did see
late money coming on the buck ladies and
gentlemen ladies and gentlemen ladies
and gentlemen it's the moment you've all
been waiting for Kelly give the people
your best bet
[Music]
alright guys we've hit seven straight
best bets after the Ravens on Sunday
night I'm looking to make it eight in a
row this week with the ugliest bet on
the board I told you guys it was gonna
be bad the Browns minus three
I have zero good things to say here
about the Browns supposedly they have a
new play caller this week but Baker
Mayfield and Freddie kitchens are still
there it doesn't matter
ask the guy asks you guys who's gonna
lay points on the road with this
Cleveland team here we are doing it this
one opened two and a half up to three
that is big money moving this and guess
what I agree with them let's go brownies
we're gonna recap all of my picks for
week ten these are listed in order of
confidence on how many units I'd
recommend you bet on each so we've got a
four unit play on the best threat that
is the brown three units Panthers
Steelers and Jets remember a unit is a
standard bet amount it should be one
percent your bankroll I've also got a
two unit play on the Viking bangles
49ers thank you so much for streaming
the show on the Bleacher Report app on
twitter on youtube this has been the bee
are betting show presented by the
Caesars Palace sports club you can
follow us on our football journey on
social I BR underscore betting good luck
on all your bets and let's go brownies
[Music]